bikal action committee meeting and we're
with author Kurt Muse the author of six
minutes to freedom
mr. muse could you set up the story for
us of your book what is it about I was a
born I'm not one I was raised in Panama
such America and I was educated in
Panama came to the states with the
college back to Panama he has and joined
my family business in that country and
but I came to power and and ruin the
country that I loved and killed a friend
of mine and burned down one of our
businesses and harassed my family and we
decided to basically take on the
government and overthrow about that
horrible dictatorship and restore a
democracy so I am but for people who are
too young to know you say Noriega came
to power huh who was he and how did that
happen general Noriega was a was a
Panamanian military colonel who through
a series of who came to the plane came
to power in Panama City
he was a drug runner he was a money
launderer he was a murderer he was a
thief and a lot of other adjectives and
this would this would have been around
he came into power in the early 80s and
and my story takes place and in
beginning in about 1987 early 87 and my
friends and I set up an underground
pro-democracy radio station we were on
the air three times a day and we very
very quickly became public enemy number
one
we were tracked down like like dogs you
brought in Cuban troops to find us
eventually in a story the book cutter
details all the things we did where we
get all the near misses all of the the
troubles that had a home the troubles in
the family I'm trying to to be a good
dad to my 15 year old daughter to my 12
year old son and my wife have been
20-some odd years trying to run my my
father's business which was down 70% in
sales and trying to overthrow the
government so all the same all the same
day was a plague imagine it was a rather
stressful environment I detail all those
those stresses and strains in the book I
was captured
I was actually betrayed not by one of my
friends with some another character in
the book who you will come to know and
to hate and I spent before you go on
what what gave you the idea what
prompted you to get involved in this
radio station why did you do it he must
have known it was risky you know that
comes a time and and at least in my life
were were were enough is enough and in
my particular case that happened one day
when I was taking my son my
twelve-year-old son Erik to school he
came to a Panamanian army roadblock
and a soldiers reached in the resend the
cart for to check to check us out to
search the car and to get our identity
papers and I saw the look on my
twelve-year-old son's face it was a look
absolute sheer care I thought myself you
know I don't live here anymore I'm not a
rich person I don't have the world with
all to leave the country so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna have him leave the
country
and I started pro-democracy underground
radio station to overthrow the dictator
and restore democracy we had a very very
good plan I mean we were we were within
a month or two of actually excuse
language which would have worked at
retrospect I believe unfortunately I was
captured I was interrogated non-stop for
days three nights and four days and the
book details all the horrors that
entails this is not your Abu Ghraib
prison this is this is this is a
third-world prison with horrible falling
people running the prison system
I survived that and I was put into to a
[ __ ] of prisoner personal Manila prison
for nine months there was nine months I
was in solitary confinement
I saw I could see sunlight but I only
saw the Sun four times in nine months so
the book details all the things that
happened to me all the things that I
witnessed all of the sort of the
emotional and spiritual journeys that I
went through how I survived how I
overcame adversity in that horrible
Harbor place
and on the eve of my execution this is
the final few chapters of the book I
want to give it away the details of it
but but essentially I was going to be
executed
and the US army Delta Force operators
soup dinner prison
and the word of the rescue mission save
me right before I was going to be
executed of course say our helicopter
was shot down so it all became it was
another saga so a couple more chapters
of us on the ground having been shot
down and having the bad guys sort of
trying to get us
you survived that as well and and then I
was reunited with my family on December
20th 1989 which you can well imagine was
the best Christmas ever for the viewers
family and to this day just so your your
viewing audience realizes is that all
the folks that participate on that
mission
many of them who will and in fact the
majority of them are moon day they all
returned to duty and all all of them
retired honorably from service and his
Army's elite unit and that we're all I'm
very close to the pound they're like
they're like brothers from a different
mother and we keep we keep in touch
what about the the larger invasion when
Manuel Noriega was at was removed by the
United States government when did that
happen and how did that fit in with his
rescue missions my my rescue preceded
the actual invasion of Panama by 15
minutes so while it happened the
invasion started and the the whole
operation lasted about two weeks and
Panama was liberated from this horrible
dictatorship mono Gloria was jailed his
staff was jailed
not that many people were killed or
injured in the end the operations
relatively speaking at Panama which
restored your democracy the interesting
thing is the Panama is in there
I think fifth or sixth round of
democratic elections there's peace in
Panama as posterity in Panama is the
number one tourist destination
retirement destination for American
citizens the Panama Canal is running
efficiently Panama College Learning fine
they're expanding the Panama Canal were
the third set of locks all these things
happen because Noriega and their
dictatorship was an island and democracy
was restored none of those things could
have happened without having a firmly
implanted Democratic former government
of Panama that I'm happy to say I tried
to do I tried to do kind of
single-handedly
fortunately the united states military
come get me up it was a began and
restoring them that country towards
freedom did you have any contact with
the Delta Force for the United States
government did you know they were coming
I had absolutely no clue that I was
going to be rescued it came as a
complete surprise as a matter of fact I
thought I was going to die because my
executioner said he was going to kill me
if somebody if somebody tried to rescue
me and and I didn't I didn't I didn't
imagine me being of any important what
so ever to have someone a unit as the
lead is the Delta Force and gotta keep
those kinds of resources to save little
Romania I was just I was I was hung on
to this day remain extremely humbled
that our country would dedicate those
kinds of research to save wife of
another American citizen in need
obviously and I just very thankful for
that right but I had I had no idea
anybody was coming why the book and how
did the book come about pardon me the
book come about and why did you write a
book it's a very good question Anna had
confessed to you for the first five
years I ever spoke about the incident it
was just such it was such a trauma to me
to my family anyone talk about the
second five years I started thinking
about it
in the third five years the first the
first part of the third five years I
started thinking that knowing actually
that I had to write the story because
when you read the book you realize that
they are there are many many many people
whose lives I touched and they touched
my life
incredible Americans in horrible
panamanians whom I was the I was a soil
controller of that slice of their family
histories so I decided that I was going
to to write it for them and I spent a
couple of years trying to find an author
and unfortunately everybody that I
interviewed everybody talked with was
had an x-ray had an angle
I see no I don't want I don't want an
angle I don't want acts I just want you
to tell the story when you read my books
expose for freedom you'll see there's
the good there's a bad
there's the ugly but it's a human story
and any and humans are frail we have all
those qualities all those quads are in
that book and
and I'm very very happy to tell you that
having written a book I've now made
contact with families and friends
families of the big was book who've come
back to me absolutely amazed that their
father or their uncle or their brother
or their cousin or their friend did
those things they're written about in a
book
I was able to tell them about their
coming and what a great American
and besides writing the book what are
you doing now right now I am I'm really
a privilege I teamed up with one of
those my mission planners a former Delta
operator and we have a very small
company and we are we are active
anok in Iraq we're helping out our
soldiers and as special missions
you know the author is Kurt Muse and the
book has six minutes to freedom thank
you very much thank you very much